It's French, it's the granddaughter of Víctor Sanz,
please tell us a little about
Víctor's daily life, a fan,
well, I'm alone when you've been
working all my life
and watching something, preparing conferences,
being something, now he can't read everything anymore
because he's almost blind, more than anything else.
time is writing
and what was the altering influence
on you
I think you have a fairly
strong influence on my life but I cannot
express what it consists of
so many things about your look
look how I live the difference between
me and a normal granddaughter  it would be that you
take off I feel a little more proud
of him than the other movements and maybe I
try a little harder
because he is right that those
trades on me
more important than the influencer is that
he has always had time for me that
is  the simplest thing is that at
any time i can come to
finish
and always
leave your job and to talk to me
that perez will also have a lot to do with my
life
and c  As he accompanies
her a lot, sometimes you have more
work than she would have sacrificed a
lot for logotherapy, that's why she
made all the trips with him
now
and to the cards
the myths she receives why she can't
give
to a very important part of her life and
It has always been good for 50 years.
First of all,
the Argentine logotherapy foundation
invited my grandfather to give a lecture
at this meeting and since he will be
90 years old at the beginning of this coming year,
the doctors will not let them leave the
long instances
but I send my dad and my
representatives
the logos of the actions I am here they were
not seen with a lot
of hospitality of friendship and sympathy
[Music]
what happens is that
and not only does my grandmother smell me, it is well
known but also
understood understood  appreciated more
more sometimes than in other parts of the world what
I already wanted to say perhaps in part is
the fact that here it is practiced and
deepened and in other parts because
the  Spooned on other occasions in
other places and rather logotherapy is practiced
logotherapist practice
but they do not teach it and they do not go into it as
much it would be like this a little I know
more about what the tribute is in Argentina than
in other other parts of the world and for
that reason  I can't say that for sure,
it has nothing to do with the edict of the
world, my impression here is that
[Music]
what I want to compare with other
logotherapy of this is something that
understanding would be the axis of the
is very significant is that  every flight
has come to Argentina four
times it is very significant that
every flight
I sent you and your father here
we really feel a gratitude
or a current in others it is also
significant that the first book in
Spanish language of every flight has been
the people
facts that have some relationship that is
interrelation from the suffering from
what may be the needs
a continent in which it has h  due to
problems including konami problems
one cannot quite understand this from the
sense of beauty of the origin of
logotherapy
in the field of consciousness
as he asked the foundation how it was
founded because the foundation is somewhat the
continuation of an Argentine society
of logotherapy that does not  we had
the foundation we did it with the aim
of growing
the best of being able to deepen the new
therapy of exchanging with other
institutions
to offer a greater possibility of
insertion in the educational field
in research at the moment we
are working a lot in the
terminal center foundation very
old
we have a lot of homework and there has been a
demand that has exceeded our
expectations
we never thought that people would
demand this psychotherapy that the
institution sold it
the response of the medical community
in general
the community in general and the
medical community maybe not so much  the community
specifically if I eat the most
bi mountain  in public culture general public that
frank is well known widely
spread throughout latin america in argentina
especially here the sales
of frank's texts is very numerous
and that makes it easy for
the public to know him back
then they demand services  courses
and we try to do all that and
not only disseminate but delve into
frank that on the different occasions
he was there I remember we also held the main
hall as a congress he said
I created logotherapy you have
to adapt it and continue to make it grow
in  this country and we have taken that a little bit
to found different courses,
we know that the most general thing is the
educational possibility, therefore there are
courses for psycho-pedagogues,
on the other hand, each healthcare task
and for legal reasons,
only doctors and psychologists can
exercise it and we have courses  of three years
for doctors and psychologists on the other hand
there are resources for the general public  With
a certain age and some
basic training, which are courses in the
analytical therapy of existence that are for
personal growth,
we are now implementing them as a result
of some experiences we have had
this year. They are close to finishing a
course for young people because of some
experiences of  high school it's
amazing how adolescents are
posed with the problem of the meaning of
life how they grasp the problem and how they
care and like to work on
it subjects like philosophy and psychology are
generally not very welcome in
high schools when they are
headed  within the version of the
in adoration that realizes that her
life does not need meaning so
that worries her and she is interested in that cancer
we have increased some workshops for
another size for adolescents
the community that works
[Music] in
the year 1924 by  first time
víctor tan to argentina and that he wants
a month between us giving courses  and
seminars at that time
with words that are almost prophetic
my homeland is the place where I understand myself
I listen to the streets and see the
possibilities that the foundation is making
these words also
have a center
and personally I have to say that in
that  opportunity is in the year 1954
thousand fathers the bulls josé tomás o
severe eyes was the first president of
the Argentine society of lobatera that
I say this with a healthy pride because I
know where
the idea that human ties are
transcendent ties that transcend comes from
the time they are creating institutions
ways of thinking I think this
story is to summarize briefly
on television
víctor tan came to the republic of Argentina
god or message was given to some
followers those followers spoke with
his disciples those disciples are
present today working in  the
argentine republic trying to
fundamentally find a meaning to the
victim existence  or sanz arrives in argentina
after the malvinas war
after the argentinian lefty really suffered
great suffering and where many
of the soldiers who had been in the
malvinas and returned to traditional psychotherapy
narrated that they made
more sense there  in the suffering of the
war than in a therapeutic office
in which he was seen coldly I
remember that on that occasion the
society sent a letter to víctor
fine telling them that we
needed his presence at this
moment in the people
and víctor ran as in all  the
opportunities in which it was requested
responded cordially and after
coming to be my sea
and I believe that this is something important
something important to tell the
contemporary generation about
the past
the conditions but it does not determine
what is the attitude of the present to which it
can  forge the future we are
children of our step
it is not created in our past
I am going to comment a little on the congr  That
last thing,
this congress was on the subject of
family and mental health,
what we tried to do
and change traditional ideas a bit,
we could say of
psychology
the greatest predicament in our country
where the family is always seen as
something negative for
the concentration camp or various  children
or otherwise the problem of the
independence of psychics will
always extend the dependency in the
homes the castro the children we
understand that something of that can happen
when there are deviations but that
normally the home and the family is the
place where one grows  where it evolves
where human beings acquire values as the l
tter said that in a course on value
and p
y in our life projec
s in what we do our children wh
are seeing the values that we com
selves to with them already coor
inated does says the man
It is what makes its use, that is, the
task that I do
is what gives me the type of values
I have that's why he has already grasped with his
grandfather the values of work the value
of dedication a mission to work from h
ving overcome as many difficult s
tuations as he had to endure how
e coped with all risks how such a
ope
ul psychology can come out of such a traumatic situation t
at  it is everything it is a life and through
the examples of life it is the transmission
of values we try to have that congr
ss in capturing all that has been seen recen
ly in may the first pan-a
erican congress of the family was held in mexic
and I was able to see a series of thing
about the family that
certified the slow idea we had
about the indisputable value of the
family and that if in the family the
impossibility of a nation the impossibility
of a country there is no possibility of community
it becomes very difficult it is intense
[Music
] logotherapy does not study at  subject as
an individual that happens to the individual
but the object of studying the battery
that being in the world and the search
health is centered
on the possibility
of people's development of a sense
of distinction,
that is why you
essay that you call the human way of getting
sick, what is raised is the
importance of the lifestyle of a
reductionist consumerist hedonistic society that diminishes man to
his  biological dimension
the possibility of the spiritual and the
transcendent which is how it produces
the human in the patient and I would really
hope that we could write a
book that was the human way of living
not the human way of being sick I think that
a society
reduces to  man to the
biological dimensions to the
psychological dimensions there is a
partiality
the contemporary problem I have no doubt
a much more bitter response than her
I believe that logotherapy is a modern vision it
is an edition with a future of the
possibilities that man has  an
answer one last question
I hope that later I will personally
respond to the influence  ia who had the
search for the meaning of life in
existence
but how
repetitive since I have
logotherapy in the background of my life of
pepper of my thoughts of everything
and apart from that I hope that he is a
normal person with normal problems
that they have  others are also
speech therapy it doesn't make me a number
[Music]
there are problems but maybe
I have the opportunity
to look for answers
and that is the advantage I have
but of course
I can't get this element of
surprise
the discovery
what happens to many people when  read for the
first time a book by my grandfather that I
can't sing
I could feel east
in a few words
my father told me
a little before he died
I think I delivered and of torches
and well then toni's
was my teacher
and above all  of this
in your presence you are
[Music] there
are
the three dimensions
the dimension of what has been given to us
this dimension of commitment to the
master
of transcendence  to
what one can have with religion
exceeds my lack of this
to have confidence in my lack of
confidence
of the search
and I believe that the only way that I can
help someone who is
at work on Sunday happy
that man of  being present
dr well I think she has told you something
very interesting with therapy she already says that she is
no longer a therapist she is a doctor of law
but I think I have done something very
therapeutic and it is that the new therapy does not
immunize it
does not make us immune to the things that
they happen, but if you meant to say,
I understand that it gives us the strength to
face these problems,
precisely, logotherapy has that, it is
the indomitable force of the spirit,
what logotherapy awakens,
and that the spirit is very strong
once the spirit wakes up, it has a lot of
strength and it has  the force precisely to
oppose and to triumph over the five
physicists
france in some passages says that the
human being is hungry for bread and that it is
important but it is not the ho  In the name of bread,
human beings are hungry for meaning and
we, as much in a world that
is fundamentally the subject of autonomic panic,
and we do not realize that there are
many other places in the world that
are panicking too,
the meaning would be for human beings if
not  has it